but I just get the sense that you're you
read a lot you're you're crazy
intelligent and you read a lot because I
feel like you you make
a would do do you read widely do you
read all just different kinds of stuff
do you like history what is it yeah
um yeah I mean I don't think I'm that
smart with like um shapes uh but
sometimes I know CU like I feel I don't
have a high IQ um but um but then I do
see other people try to like pack up the
car and then I'm like oh maybe I do have
a high IQ because cuz I see them trying
to fit sort of like a chair into the
trunk like clearly the wrong way and I'm
like wow I thought I had a low IQ but
I'm watching this guy put this
chair he just can't figure out that's
not going to close but if you just
tilted all right and I let him go a
while and and then you know I help help
out sort of gently cuz uh that's what
girls have to do
uh
and watching a slow motion
train and I oh okay you thought of that
all right and uh sure let me give it a
whirl um but uh yeah I guess it was I
was a film and philosophy uh double
major uh in the abstract at Tish uh
dropped that so yeah I'm pretty
uneducated uh and very self-taught
therefore well I mean it sounds to me
like you're educated in the best way
which is your self-educated yeah so it's
a a rambling sort of much like how I
talk and exist and move through life H
but it's a you know like a rabbit hole
that's you remember the 90s I think I
read something because this really stuck
in my mind which is I think it's when
you were in rehab you said you walked
around with a giant biography of
Rasputin oh yeah and I was thinking oh
this is my kind of person because I am I
I like to read about the darkest
weirdest people Rasputin has always
fascinated me and uh I just thought um
you know I I there's something about
that kind of that's that's how my mind
works is that I think that's what I
would walk around and be I probably
wouldn't be reading the uplifting book
they would want me to read on my path to
Better Health and here are the steps and
things like that I would find a very
very dark figure in history and read
their biography and it would give me
some kind of Solace yeah and uh I don't
want to burst your bubble but um
Rasputin biography was something that I
was carrying around while I was on drugs
uh in rehab it was more like I got very
into um uh I was reading Thomas Pinchin
against the day I was so excited when it
came out because it was like a thousand
pages and you know there's nothing to do
with rehab except uh you
know sit on a sofa and they feed you a
lot and uh so uh yes I really associate
Rasputin with like a back pocket kind of
you know New York
99s like the the scumbag era but I
remember finding it in my storage space
and I still have the same copy of it and
um I I love it it's very ragged I really
put that that Rasputin through hell and
it's like that kind of was he's hard to
he's hard to kill
too famously hard to kill that guy that
guy and I was like the I
took him through though my God you know
um but yeah I was uh uh reading uh a lot
and often and widely and uh also movies
you know um because their film school
was so expensive right they wanted like
60 Grand a semester or some and I
was like
honey yes you're nuts so that's a you
know like rich kid and what I did I
bought this uh this studio apartment uh
that was gry adjacent uh and I spent my
um I had $100,000 from all these jobs it
was a I think uh krippendorf's tribe is
what what gave me that money which is a
a blackface movie if you haven't seen it
it's a Disney uh blackface picture um
and stting Richard DF rind dorf's tribe
I remember that uh yes uh so the premise
is that uh Richard dfish is a an
anthropologist whose wife dies and now
he's a sad widower with these two three
kids and so he decides to
create a a fake tribe in his backyard oh
yes it's it's worse than you think and
uh and so then essentially
it's all of us Richard drus myself and
uh I guess the other two uh Sons I'm I'm
the eldest um all in full blackace
uh how have I never heard of this people
yeah wow it's pretty nuts so you chose a
good you chose a good time to get out I
think let's go to a clip
yeah 1998 1998 and so I took that money
and I um uh I was like a I'll just
buy an apartment cuz the other money all
my childhood acting money had been spent
already um not by you no and I I thought
I was going to get a Lambo that's why I
was doing it um I was Pro I was promised
that I was going to get a Lambo but I
never materialized um but I did get a
bad credit score early because my social
security number was being used
frequently um so yeah you know going to
the film forum for the quadruple
feature
was so much cheaper than Tish um so
that's why I dropped out I bought the
apartment you know and so your
film school was just watching a ton of
films yeah but I mean like this rabbit
whole thing that used to happen um in
our our times um the before times MH
when you would uh you know you had to go
read and search and dig and go to the
Strand to follow up on the
okay so who is this George kakor
all right okay Billy Wilder what you got
like you know you would go down a rabbit
hole and then figure out who Philip
Marlo is and you know see the sort of
lineage there and understand you know
pre-code Hollywood and you know this
Haze code who the is this Haze
and so I think that that sort of selft
and it was always with the sort of the
things that that seem to be plaguing you
uh tilt to it
of um you know what's it all about Alfie
um and death and these things and uh
really the thing that it was really but
it was in uh in reham that I really
started connecting directly to science
because in high school it was not my
thing um but uh I remember reading this
uh Bill Bryson book uh walk in the woods
which one no it's um I don't know
history of nearly everything yes yeah
yeah and I was like oh okay I think I
can use that concept as like this higher
power concept because it was
so uh impossible to sort of reconcile um
I whatever you know what is this idea of
uh uh you know like an anthropomorphic
God or whatever um and I really
understood the scope of how little I
understood about the world do you know
what I mean like it's a very narrow
thing that I'm an expert in which is
like uh you know drugs mental health and
like Cinema of the 70s um but that book
really opened my eyes like just how
inconsequential I was in the scheme of
things and that there was so much I
didn't even well that okay that is the
uh philosophy idea that has been the the
greatest Comfort to me in like the last
20 years it's just the more I know the
less I know I I try to read a lot I try
to listen to people I try to understand
things and the more I understand things
the more I'm humbled by the vast amount
that I don't know and I take I said this
a couple of years ago in an interview
and people thought well he's really dark
or he's I remember it was like Conan's
goth but I was basically saying you know
I think nothing I do in this life is
going to outlast me that much and I I
think soon after we go um besides my my
my wife and my kids I don't think that
it's going to mean that much to people
and I mean that in a comforting way
meaning it's the it feels like the
pressure's off in a way if you don't get
I think too many when people get wrapped
up in this concept of I'll live forever
or this my work and how will I be
remembered I think that's a huge waste
of time you know it's an ego trip and
it's a you know yeah it's like uh what
I've heard the best thing about the the
12 steps I've heard is it's like you're
uh deconstructing the house that ego
built you know um right and uh yeah I
mean it's a NeverEnding nightmare uh you
know being a person because uh you know
the truth of the matter is you feel good
with when your chips are up and you feel
bad when they're down or like you send a
text message and you don't get the reply
you want you're like what the I do
and you spend four hours thinking about
it and then the text comes in and you're
like oh now that's a yesterday's
problem I guess we're back baby like and
it's so weird you know what I
mean like it's weird that every day you
have to kind of play this game of sort
of having a good day driving my car or I
a piece of um couldn't couldn't
hail a taxi and you know uh I I I I I
love the animate objects and uh
Logistics um they seem to be two real
troublemakers you know uh you loathe
inanimate objects yeah now wait a minute
uh I know what you mean if you if you
mean what I think you mean I find that
the minute I care about something that I
can hold in my hand I will misplace it
fairly soon and I will spend about six
hours worrying about where it is even if
it costs like $42 yeah I will devote
time to being very upset that that thing
I liked having I can't find now and then
I will find it like six days later in an
obvious spot and be way Overjoyed about
that and realize that I just ate up more
of this precious time on Earth worrying
about the you know $60 bite pen that I
bought here in Larchmont that uh has a
cool sort of orange tone to the cap that
I liked doodling with and then it was
gone for 6 days and I was bereft but now
I found it again oh why would I put it
inside a sock why did I do that what
made me think of that but here it is yay
I've got that pen back and it's crazy
and then who closer to the Grave good
job Conan good little soap opera yeah
but it's I mean I understand what you're
saying that's what I'm saying yeah
exactly what I'm saying like what the
are these things it's like oh
where's this bottle cap oh okay now
you're a Magical Mystery Tour cool glad
this is happening I mean it's
nuts I had a okay I had this moment of
Awakening yeah when I years ago in New
York when I worked in 30 Rock across the
street was Christy's auction house and
one day they said oh all of the
Roosevelt family memorability is being
put up for auction and I thought well I
got to go check that out so I went over
and it's Franklin Roosevelt and Elanor
and then they had a bunch of kids and so
basically I went and looked and it was
room after room after room of all the
stuff they had given each other for
Christmases going back to like
1922 up until you know past when
Franklin's gone and well into the 1950s
and it was just case after case after
case of stuff that looked like you know
that's a tie clip that's a a little
watch fob oh look there's a little case
you can put some pills in oh look
there's a little I yeah there's a
bookmarker that's made of
peor uh and it was thousands and
thousands of them it was like the end of
Citizen Cane where I'm looking at all of
it and I'm imagining is them unwrapping
it on Christmas Day
1931 well isn't that
grand thank you thank you look at that's
going to hold my tie quite nicely thank
you
yay Christmas
1935 well isn't that grand that's going
to keep my place in the book and now
everyone's dead and it's a room full of
and everyone's buying it and then
they're going to give it to somebody
it's going to be like hey thanks that's
fantastic that'll hold my tie in
place and then they're going to die yes
and it's just then we're just I don't
know that's what I don't know why that
one christe's auction just opened my
eyes to what a sh the whole thing is y I
love goth
Conan well you're all going to die
everybody you're all going to die God
Conan's a
okay